His beta-glucan, good for everyone, I would say beta-glucan isn't bad for anybody, beta-glucan
is a polysaccharide, typically it's from heighten or it's from mushrooms, that's what
beta-glucan is, so it's a polysaccharide, polysaccharides are indefinition in immune modulator
and so if a person has a suppressed immune system, they're trying to fight cancer, it will help
boost their immune system to be able to fight cancer, so I don't think they're necessarily
bad for anybody, however it's not just because something's bad doesn't mean we don't need
to be taking everything, so I think a better than beta-glucan is the evolved immune product
because that's got the polysaccharides in the exact right number, so a polysaccharide
is saccharides that are bonded together and I have written some things and did some videos
on the evolved immune product, the number of polysaccharides which makes it the best to kill infections
and to kill cancer cells.